collapse here he alerted his father
both of them thought she tripped and
Fallen but she had been shot by members
of Israeli forces raiding the Janine
refugee camp while she was in the
courtyard of her home
she was speaking to her cousins through
the window I told her to shut them down
because snipers sometimes shoot at
onlookers so she asked me if she could
go see them I said of course thinking
she would be safer her family says she
filmed this video it's shaky but shows
the moment she was shot
I didn't think she would be shot that
fast I was just talking to her I looked
and found her laying here on the ground
brain dead she died from her
either wounds might never
friends describe a popular and friendly
girl passionate about folk dancing and
theater like her classmates she'd seen a
lot of death
people here know that life in the camp
is always uncertain
they say she was killed in Cold Blood
we're used to playing this very place
where she was killed we used to play
hopscotch here all the time now memories
are all they have left of her
sadil was buried here in the camp
Cemetery it is where children often come
to visit the graves of their peers
walking in the cemetery one cannot fail
to notice that there are many small
Graves rights organizations say that at
least 30 miners were killed by Israeli
forces since the beginning of this year
Israeli forces did not comment on her
killing the day she was shot several
soldiers were injured after Palestinians
planted explosive devices in the camp
sadil's friends tell us they want to
fight for her right to justice but don't
know how her brother Muhammad is going
to turn 10 in August he says his sister
is now in a much better place Ibrahim
al-jazeera the occupied West Bank